well gymnasts are some of the world's
greatest athletes and we have some here
locally
getting ready to compete in an
international championship later this
month
rocky is live with the biggest
acrobatics program
in nevada to show us what it takes to go
for the gold hey rocky
hey you guys yeah so we are at agc
that's acrobatics gymnastics
circus right ross this is the boss man
right here he's going to coach me
through
this move up hands on head right hands
on head okay up on there straight to
work
good job all right i'm channeling my
inner simone biles right now
okay ready and then
well done did i stick it you did it nice
thing you're perfect perfect
okay so while after my debut here we're
gonna go to the pros now and talk to you
about a competition coming up later this
month
so ross introduce us what's going on so
we're here because we have vlad
stodwell and davis levitt competing for
the us
in the 11 to 16 men's pairs category at
this year's world championships in
switzerland
later this month go ahead lance look at
the look at them look at the pros in
action
so tell us about this duo here because
obviously we have a younger one and an
older one
how does it work so we have uh davis is
obviously the older one he's the base
and he's about to throw vlad for one of
their impressive
dynamic skills here back some assault to
catch back on the hands
and uh vlad is 10 years old and he's
actually going to be probably the
youngest competitor at this year's world
championships as
they have to be 11 in the year of
competition so 16 year old davis
11 year old vlad competing for the us
incredible i'm mesmerized watching them
i feel like i'm a little underdressed i
need my
i mean my dazzling jumpsuit for this you
need some gemstones and rhinestones yeah
so tell us about the program itself what
does it take to you know compete for the
gold
well um there's different disciplines
that you can compete in acrobatic
gymnastics men's pairs which is these
two you also have mixed pairs male and a
female
women's pairs two women women's groups
of three women and men's groups of
four men so you have a lot of chances to
be able to go to international
competitions in acrobatic gymnastics
that is incredible there's in fact 50
competitors from the us going
to switzerland this week and it all
starts right here in this gym so invite
the parents who are watching or people
who are watching down to
visit the gym and maybe get their kids
into this program so they can get
on the big stage one day so we're at agc
las vegas here on warm springs and
rainbow and we have a great program for
acrobatic gymnastics gymnastics
rhythmic gymnastics circus trampoline
tumbling everything here that people can
perform
and if they want to give their hand at
crow they can well i'm certainly not
ready to
you know end my career here i'm ready to
go for it again okay
let's do it again all right we'll see
you back in the floor guys
rocky we're expecting four o'clock i
want to see a backflip i mean her
jumping off was very impressive but i've
seen those guys we've got to see some
tumbling
i want her to join the duo and make it a
trio
and see what they can do together they'd
be perfect